ça c'est mon robinet un litre toutes les
dix secondes par jour vous diriez que
vous confirmez de combien de litres
d'eau dilidjan même pas neuf les villes
et probablement une cinquantaine
peut-être qu athlète à montréal et moyen
consomme 300 litres par jour les gens
soient ça et 308 litres pour être précis
mon robinet devrait couler pendant 50
minutes pour atteindre ce volume
la moyenne au québec 5 173 litres par
personne chaque jour 447 à l'échelle du
canada
le problème ici c'est qu'on ne peut pas
vraiment être précis au québec on a pas
encore d'accord résidant à faire non
connect après les maires seront donc la
façon que la quantité consommée par lta
et calculer c'est enfin l'ensemble de
l'eau traitée par les usa et on le
divise par le nombre d'habitants mais au
secours et contre les compteurs pour les
particuliers pour protéger l'accès
universel à l'eau depuis 2011 le québec
a une stratégie d'économie de l'eau
potable qui a forcé commerce et
industrie à s'équiper de conteur et donc
avoir une lecture réel de leur
consommation et québec demandent aux
villes de faire la même chose sur un
échantillon de résidences privées pour
affiner les estimations beaucoup sont en
retard mais ce n'est pas le cas de
bromont par exemple qui aura installé
ses 60 compteur à la fin de l'été en
fait ça va déterminer où est ce qu'on va
mettre nos efforts pour induire cette
réduction du gaspillage de l'eau donc si
jamais on se rend compte que la
consommation résidentielle est déjà
extrêmement basses nous efforcerons
tourner plus vers un autre réseau de
vente lui parce que les fuites dans le
réseau c'est encore un quart du
gaspillage de l'eau
celle ci par exemple dure depuis une
semaine à montréal où chaque km de
conduits perd l'équivalent de cette
piscine chaque jour limiter les fuites
c'est donc l'objectif numéro 1 des
villes il ya aussi la sensibilisation
majeur on appelle ça une structure est
elle donc c'est les pommeaux de douche
l'étoile r d électroménager qui
consomment beaucoup d'eau depuis hier
dans six arrondissements de montréal
hydro québec s'associe aux éco quartiers
pour échanger votre pomme de douche trop
gourmande contre une à débit réduit
parce qu'il faut savoir que si on
économise de l'eau sous la douche on
économise aussi de l'eau chaude et donc
on sauve de l'électricité et donc des
sous sur sa faction
mais d'ailleurs combien elle coûte l'eau
potable en fait sauf exception c'est
inclus dans les taxes municipales
exemple à montréal dans un duplex évalué
à 400 mille dollars s'il n'y a que deux
personnes
ça reviendra à 1 dollars 83 par mètre
cube mais seulement 43 cents s'il y a
deux familles
ces quinze fois moins que la moyenne
européenne
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal